welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the mandalorian season 2
released a new special look trailer
ahead of its second season premiere on
october 30th and while there's still no
sighting of ahsoka tano or moff gideon's
larping gear
after i did my reaction we got a woo
i have since gone through this footage
frame by frame and actually there is
some huge stuff hidden in here huge i'm
gonna break down all the easter eggs and
easter seal guys
let's get started
okay mando's razor crest is being chased
down by the new republic's
x-wings like the ones we saw last season
in episode six now in other footage
these x-wings appear to have some red
paint on the nose some blue stripes on
the wing cannon
maybe there's a blue astromech droid
there could this be
luke skywalker in r2d2 well now that we
hear the pilot doesn't really sound like
mark hamill
stand down but i think he will show up
in this season he did cameo as the mos
eisley droid bartender in season one
and i will say the voice of gore koresh
the abyssian does sound a bit more
hammily than fabreauy this is no place
for a child
wherever i go he goes so i've heard now
i don't think this x-wing chase is
necessarily from the same scene as
mando's crash landing on this ice planet
which again i believe to be ilum
the ice planet once mined for kyber
crystals and visited by the jedi with
young leads to get the crystals for
their lightsabers which
also showed up in jedi fell in order and
30 years later was terraformed into
starkiller base by the first order
those walls do look a lot like the illum
ice walls you gotta climb in jedi fall
in order let's move on
i'm here on business i need your help
i've been quested to bring this one back
to its kind
okay here mando meets grieve karga and
kara doon on navarro but mando's audio
is probably
from a different scene because think
about it cara and grief were already
present with mando when the armorer
assigned him that mission why would he
repeat it to them here they'd be like
yeah yeah we know we were there so i
think the audio is actually from scene
with mando media
sabine wren or bocaton freeze or ahsoka
tano mandalorian characters themselves
or
characters with connections to other
mandalorians and with the jedi to help
mando trace baby oda's origin
but cool detail here look in the razor
crest behind mando there
is somebody frozen in carbonite back
there so either mando could be bringing
grief another bounty or
i think he's getting back a bounty that
he returned to him before because he
probably caught this later in the
trailer there's a sighting of that blue
mithral played by horacio sands in the
first episode of the series
he shows up in the cockpit with cara
angry he was last seen frozen in
carbonite handed off to grief in
exchange for
mon calamari currency just connecting
some dots here i think one of their
missions is going to involve mando and
grief and cara breaking into an imperial
base on navarro
that that mithral was handed over to now
i assume it was imperial forces because
remember grief tried to pay mando
initially in imperial credits
before offering a calamari flan currency
and the shot of them in the trailer here
could be
after they broke out the mithral and
then maybe because he was annoying mando
refroze him in order to transport him to
his ocean home world that could connect
to the footage of the water planet we've
seen
maybe moncala they could be returning
this mithral to his home planet in order
maybe to curry favor with his family in
order to help nano track down contacts
with the old rebel alliance people like
bo katan
or sabine wren whom sasha banks may be
plain in hooded form appearing on these
docks
and in the shots of that seaport mando
does follow two beings one of whom wears
a backpack with this
tank we actually saw a funko pop
figurine with baby yoda in a similar
looking
egg canister and you do see what look
like eggs floating around in that girl's
tank
perhaps there is a mon cala aquatic race
needing their eggs back
and this mithral is the key and whatever
the reason moth gideon's imperial unit
had those eggs is the same reason he
wants the
child babiona may be connected to dr
pershing's kamino linked genetic
engineering now some believe the shots
of mando's feet are actually a different
character
boba fett's boots but i don't think so
you can see the tip of mando's rifle
dropping down in the frame there
really boba fett is another character we
have yet to see in any trailer footage
we do know that timmy olefant is going
to be playing a character this season
and there was a report by slash film
that he was seen wearing boba fett's
armor
on set but we also got another report
that were morrison is going to return as
boba fett so i think it's more likely
that ole fan is going to be playing
cobb vance a character from chuck
wendig's aftermath series
cobb was the self-appointed sheriff of
freetown on tatooine who got his hands
on the acid-stained armor
of boba fett scavenged by jawas and the
dune sea
in the wreckage of jabba's barge but
we'll just have to see how both that and
or cobb banff connect to that mystery
man we saw at the end of episode five
but before we move on these tattooing
dunes do include this
skeleton those are the curved horns of
abantha
it is similar to the famous crepe dragon
skeleton in the dune sea in a new
hope but other big things die here too
well hey before i continue thank you to
skillshare for sponsoring this video
skillshare is an online learning
community that offers membership with
meaning with so much to explore
real projects to create and the support
of fellow creatives skillshare empowers
you to accomplish
real growth skillshare offers classes
designed for
real life you can learn and grow with
short classes that fit
any schedule if you think about these
days spontaneous acts of creativity may
help
break up the routine of a day spent
indoors and learning is a great way to
fend off boredom that's what we believe
here at new rockstars we're all about
learning something new every day
skillshare has classes and topics new
rockstars fans will enjoy like animation
film video music production the kind of
fun nerdy things that make watching
movies and trailers all the more
rewarding a class i want to check out is
science fiction and fantasy
creating unique and powerful worlds
taught by lincoln michelle
a creative writing professor at columbia
and sarah lawrence the class focuses on
how to create new and unique worlds
while having those worlds reflect back
on us and making us see our reality
differently
skillshare is curated specifically for
learning there are no ads and they are
always launching new premium classes so
that you can stay focused and follow
wherever your creativity takes you
and it's less than ten dollars a month
with an annual subscription
and the first 1000 of my subscribers to
click that link in the description will
get a free trial of premium membership
so that you can explore your creativity
with skillshare all right let's move on
if i can locate other mandalorians
they can guide me
this is no place for a child
wherever i go he goes okay crashed on
the ice planet the razer crest appears
to be oozing this teal colored fluid
maybe it's fuel or maybe it's
blood of something else smeared on the
ship and that mando could be looking
up at it because also notice how in the
shot tilting down on the ship in the
cave that snow is going up
the billowing smoke is condensing in
instead of dispersing
us tenant heads no this shot is reversed
and i'm guessing it's because the normal
shot is gonna be a reveal of some
monster
lurking overhead because then notice in
the other shot there is the carcass of
an ice spider
the size of a dog curled up on the wing
of the razor crest
but even more terrifying lean back from
your screen here
this ship is covered in the segmented
legs of a
giant ice spider mama spider i hate this
and you know mando does too because now
he's gotta cut through the giant spider
parts to free his ship how he brought
this thing down
i don't know but he does have a little
crazy baby wizard who can take down mud
horns so mando's voice over here
mentions
locating other mandalorians to guide him
and since he already knows other
mandalorians from navarro
i'm assuming he's referring to
mandalorians he doesn't yet know it
alongside links to jedi characters like
bo katan sabine wren it's sasha banks is
playing sabian it's worth pointing out
that she is rumored to be credited for
all eight episodes this season so yeah
that plays out then there are the shots
we've seen before of mando meeting gore
correction the tatooine gomori and
fighting match this time we actually see
mando's whistling birds ignite and take
out these dudes though if you look
closely
one of those birds seems to go directly
right back in amanda's face
couch again i do think some of these
gangsters are part of the old criminal
gang of jabba the hutt one of the other
shots of carrot dune does show her in a
setting that looks like the arch
ceilings of jabba's palace
let's move on
okay there are more shots of their
mission against this imperial base
it is set up near a lava river and
there's some debate over what planet
this is i really do think it is just
navarro that planet does have flowing
lava on the surface
it could be sullust it could be mustafar
but why we already know there is an
imperial presence on navarro a lava
planet
in this series that could just go to
where they already are it does look like
after freeing the mithral from prisoner
holding
grief and cara have hijacked an imperial
troop transport is just like the one we
saw storm troopers arrive on in episode
seven of last season though
looks like the troop holding area has
been replaced
with gun mounts and this fluid tank
maybe fuel maybe good but i'm thinking
containing those
eggs that i mentioned before okay on to
the final clip
here we go
all right we see some outland tie
fighters screaming
well behind them some lava is smoldering
exploding up
maybe based on some other footage that
imperial base may get consumed by
geyserine lava maybe some kind of deal
do take out this base
rid the imperial presence from navarro
to allow grief cargo who's now risen up
as the leader of that town
to not to deal with storm troopers
breathing down his neck and then our
last shot
mando jetpacks over the cliff's edge to
his system whatever this extraction is
amazing how that cape avoids catching
fire knock it
but i do love how the composer lavig
your instance mando flute theme mixes
into the
intense score here
[Music]
here we go
kind of reflecting the character of
mando throughout the chaos of his
surroundings mando stays cool
true to himself unrattled ow i just
tipped my hand on the thing we're gonna
be covering mandalorian episodes with
two videos per week at least
our wikileaks after show with me and
tommy giving our first thoughts and then
my in-depth breakdown of all the easter
eggs visual details that you missed
subscribe to wikileaks wherever you get
your podcasts
subscribe to us here on newrockstars on
youtube hit that notification bell
follow me
on instagram ea boss follow me rockstars
thank you for watching i
have spoken
[Music]